haarde ait jamais c'était épouvantable
le facteur va arriver d'une minute à
l'eau et malice n'est pas terminée à les
caramels les caramels il m'en faut 2 kg
le kilo de karachi par les coûts de
françois ce n'est pas le moment discuter
je n'ai pas une minute excuse moi j'ai
lu j'ai dû moi quand même ce qui arrive
mais ce n'est pas grave j'ai grosse
commande à faire pour le kiosque analyse
n'est pas terminée le fait va arriver
d'une minute à l'autre je n'y arriverais
pas c'est déjà l'heure de sa tournée et
moite et une lettre urgente a terminé
julie j'y vais je te laisse bonjour mes
très chers amis ce matin je suis très
heureux parce que j'y suis enfin arrivé
à quoi ces miroirs inventé un jeu dont
les enfants de l'est le vent fou
amoureux et pongo achevé devenir très
populaire presque plus de bonbons
acidulés fois seulement je recommande à
mes wilma seconde liste en main
qu'est-ce que j'en ai fait j'ai dit j'ai
perdu ma maman sûr que je n'y arriverai
jamais alors que c'est la seconde fois
que je la perds je m'en doutais casimir
qu'est ce qui t'arrive que si j'ai
d'abord dit bonjour doucement réputé n'a
pas entendu alors j'ai cru que été
chaude alors c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
mal quand je m'en fiche je n'ai pas le
temps d'écouter des explications j'ai
une grosse commande affaires propos tu
m'as pas apporter ta commande de de
caramel à la moutarde et dragées au
point mais non j'ai oublié et coupe
genre je vais la chercher tout de suite
voilà je crois qu'il est temps d'aller
annoncer la bonne nouvelle recevoir un
accueil triomphal à katyn y arrête toi
j'ai une bonne nouvelle qui va te
laisser pleins d'émerveillement bon
c'est sûr mais si vous voulez
m'émerveiller laissez moi passer mais je
voulais te dire que j'ai inventivité je
n'ai vraiment pas le temps d'écouter vos
histoires j'ai autre chose à faire en
février très désagréable être reçu comme
ça se compte en a une excellente
nouvelle à annoncer
enfin bon casimir n'est pas la seule
personne de ville n'est ce pas ma très
chère amie bourget 19 ça n'est pas
l'homme avant de me déranger je vous en
prie passez votre chemin
c'est comme ça que vous vous recevez
c'est quand même pénible de ne pas
pouvoir travailler 2 minutes 45
concentrons-nous que déconvenue françois
sinon n'ont pas le temps monsieur
duchesneau briller bien que je suis
occupé pour faire qu'on soit j'avais dit
donnons plus tard monsieur liste plus
tarder à montséret mille pardons
j'ai pas le temps un short à ces prêts
d'oublier
elle est un facteur qu'elle rate ont
vite vite
voilà ma commande merci merci quasiment
tous les facteurs jeunes et chaque
lettre est très urgent hôte allait très
bien merci
j'aurais juste les tons
[Musique]
pour sûr que c'est agréable de pouvoir
se reposer dans ce jardin
après une journée de rues de labeur vous
avez tout à fait raison facteurs et vous
savez qu'il y en a qui croient que dans
l'île aux enfants nous nous reposons
pourtant nous travaillons beaucoup au
oui bah oui mais nous avons plein d'amis
aussi tu devrais casimir sans compter
tous ceux qui nous regardent chez eux a
pour sûr on n'est pas malheureux
hélène nous sommes très heureux dans
l'île aux enfants
je crois que c'est parce que l'on aime
ce que l'on fait pas vrai et bien léché
du snob mais qu'est ce qui lui arrive
rien vu leurs valises regardez sa tête
au monde ont soulevé petit une île mais
mais c'est pas possible monsieur
duchesneau me suis dit je te brûler vous
cher françois je le regret de vous dire
que je quitte lille par le prochain
bateau c'est pas vrai vous repartez des
gens en vacances monsieur du jeune homme
en jean françois weill et avoir
l'obligeance de dire à cet individu que
je ne pars pas en vacances et que je
quitte lille définitivement mais c'est
incroyable mais pourquoi parce que je me
suis aperçu amèrement que met soi disant
amis ne m'aimait pas au dessus du snap
vous pensez pas ce que vous dites à etc
étant inutile sur 7 il était préférable
pour moi de la quitter et de vous
oublier à jamais mais monsieur du snob
je sais que c'est impossible vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça plus rien ne me
retient ici
non non non c'est impossible mois que
vais-je devenir sans vous je ne sais pas
indispensable missiles enfin monsieur le
juge vous êtes le sol qui apprécie mais
mes sculptures mes peintures mes dessins
mais je de moore collège d'avenir sans
vous
bon tu crois mes pieds je veux faire de
ma bassin avec qui ce sera moi lors des
courses en sac
je ne sais pas moi sommes monsieur vous
ne pouvez pas me laisser tout seul c'est
pas possible sans vous ma vie ne sera
qu'un long désespoir à gazinet a
parfaitement raison monsieur 10900 vous
l'île aux enfants nés n'est plus tout à
fait la même monsieur du snav
j'étais un peu nerveuse j'avais beaucoup
de travail vous me pardonnez comment ne
pas vous pardonnez ma chère amie
moi aussi monsieur du sndj je vous dois
des excuses je mets ce n'était pas
méchant vous savez non mais non au
cernil ce n'était pas mes cendres et de
ma part non plus vous savez monsieur du
snop c'était pas méchant mais j'étais
tellement pris par ma lettre
je veux bien l'admettre monsieur du snob
oui vous restez eh bien oui je dis moi
comment comptiez-vous partir et bien en
bateau pourquoi mon beau casimir vous
savez très bien pour qu'un bateau ne
part de livres aujourd'hui oui oui je
sais que mes jeux je tentais prendre le
yacht de la comtesse le yacht de la
comtesse mais moi je donne à tout le
monde sait qu'il n'y a pas de compter
sur lui aux enfants ah oui je sais mais
je
[Musique]